hey this is pete peppers with a candy
crush soda saga
level 120 walk through
with some commentary
this is probably one of the toughest
levels in the game right now
since they changed out some of the
hardest ones in the last
update so
i was getting ready to write the guide a
lot of players were asking about this in
the group and
in the comments of the site so
i realized that it is really hard
and when i was first playing it this
morning
i wasn't having a whole lot of luck with
different things i was trying
but did manage to figure out that there
is a
i don't know if you'd call a trick or
strategy but um
there's something you can do to really
improve your chances
so
i'm just gonna go ahead and make this
video
see if i could beat it
in real time and explain to you how i go
about it the last room is the is the key
that's where
i was having all my problems
and
that's where you really have to
make some good decisions
and approach it the right way and the
first levels you just want to get out of
here as fast as you can in all of them
um i'll write more in the guide about it
but you know you don't really want to
stockpile specials because as you can
see they all kind of get blown up as you
move from room to room anyways
so you just want to conserve as many
moves as you can
one of the first times i played this
morning i had um
tremendous amount of specials in the
last room
i started off with um two
color bombs that i matched together on
the very first match in that room then i
had a color bomb
and a fish and then a coloring candy and
a striped and i still didn't finish
so
that's sort of why i
wanted to look at it a little bit closer
and see if i could figure out a way to
make it a little bit easier
it's
it's straight it strikes me as one that
um
you know a lot of people will say oh i
hate this level because it's all locked
and a lot of times when i hear that
you know in a guide or in the comments
on the videos or something
that roughly translates into
i've played this level a bunch of times
and i didn't
magically complete it
so it must take luck
and
i don't know how many times you'd have
to play this one over and over in order
to get lucky to finish it but i would
think it would be in the hundreds
all right so here we are this is where
everything
gets real important
all right so this is where things where
you really have to um
plan things out and it's frustrating
because it's a really small space here
so
we have 21 moves which is not bad
if you have less than that it's going to
be tough most of the time
but what i figured out that helped me a
lot
to finally finish it and hopefully
finish it here again
is um
there's there's a color bomb right here
and there's a coloring candy right here
this stuff on the side has a lot of
layers and there's bears there too but
the hardest pairs to get are always in
this last row
and since this board is pretty good for
cascades
rather than trying to go left and right
it's much better to go straight down
and things will start to open up a lot
faster
if you go in a straight line so
in situations like this yeah we want to
make the um
we can fire out the stripes which is
going to go where we want but we'd want
to make the um
wrap candy first because it'll drop down
and
we got another wrap so i think here
what we'll want to do is instead of
firing that off at all we'll use
we'll use the double wrap because it's
going to end up right around here
and give us a nice five by five
explosion
and it'll shoot off this anyway so
so at this point we've um
we've used up five of our moves
but look how much of the sides and
things that we got cleared out without
even really focusing on those
so we'll scan the board
we do want to look
for spots where we might be able to make
color bombs or coloring candies
but we know that we have them right here
so
since i don't see anything
really fantastic i'm just going to go
ahead and make a wrap
and set off this wrapped in the process
which is going to take us down
and
it's going to you know start chain
reaction where both of them go off
all right so now we do have a color bomb
match here
i don't see any reason why we shouldn't
make that
and we have another one here or we could
go for the striped which we could match
with our color bulb
there aren't a lot of green on the board
though right now
and
we do have a set up for a strike here as
well
so i'm gonna go ahead and make the color
bomb
and
these color bonds are cool and all but
we don't want to move away from our
strategy which is to go straight down
so
what's the best way to do that right now
alright good so now we can do this
that'll be good
and i guess i went a little bit fast but
the reason i went over this on this side
to make that match is because
going down next to this color bomb will
be just as good as
taking taking the layer off the top of
it so this one's sort of a no-brainer
too because we can
we can match the blue
and it's going to take the layer off of
that collect this bear and it's also
going to leave this
fish right here so we can use it right
away
well
didn't work out exactly as planned but
we do have this set up now so we'll go
ahead and do that we're going to lose
this color bomb but
that's okay
all right so we have five more bears
they're all in this bottom half
you can see that
there's none up here and then here
i don't know if they're all in the
bottom row or i don't remember to be
honest so
all right we have nine moves left things
have been going pretty good
but we are definitely not out of the
woods yet
i'm gonna go ahead and make this this is
gonna take a layer off the coloring
candy and set up a color bomb over here
and our color and candy got messed up
but that's okay
that's gonna happen a lot on this level
so now
if i set this off
it will
if i just made this like make the fish
and take a layer
and set this off it'll blow up the color
and candy in the process
so i'm going to do instead
is i'm going to
make the three orange match that's going
to remove the bear and put that wrap
candy right next to the coloring candy
but we're going to see how things set up
after because i'm not sure
there's two layers on this cotton candy
right now so
i'm not sure if it's gonna
all right so this is pretty good
we can drop this yellow one down and
free the coloring candy
to set up this match and we'll still
have a couple of moves left to clean
things up if we need them so
i don't think we have to worry about any
of this other stuff that's going on
right now
because we just don't want to waste any
moves
same here
no reason to mess around with that
all right so now we have
the coloring and the wrapped i think
use that right away
they're both orange so it'll take on a
different color it looks like it might
change the green
um
you don't really know though
i changed the blue so that's pretty good
so that should finish things up for the
most part
so we have a bear here here and here
we can take this
these two down a layer
we have two choices here we can
make a color bomb it'll be sitting next
to another color bomb
or we can make a color bomb
maybe sitting next to a striped
colorblind plus color guard is only
going to take off one layer and we need
three layers off of this one and two off
of these
you can see like now with the boards all
the way up and we have color collarbone
matches all over the place
and this is why like i said it's not
really about luck it's about making the
right decisions when you have things set
up correctly
and this is a big one so i'm gonna i'm
gonna go with the color bomb plus the
striped
and we'll have two moves left
to hopefully get that last one
and it worked out and then we have two
left and it's done and
that's really the trick is to go
straight down in the last room save all
your moves do the best you can
to move as fast as you can don't hoard
the um
specials at all
and then when you get in this room just
go straight down the middle and really
take your time you know you could see
there i had all kinds of good stuff
going on and i still almost didn't
finish it so
i hope this helps
make sure you read the guide if you
hadn't and like the video if you found
it useful
visit our site
candycrushsodasagatips.com and be sure
to subscribe to our channel to get more
videos like this which we'll be making
soon alright thanks